Olá
tudo bem
bom gente
está todo mundo em pânico mas acho que
essa é uma pergunta que claramente a
resposta é sim mas os motivos que eu
gostaria de explorar com vocês aqui
vão para uma história que aconteceu
comigo lá em Julho de 2002 eu tava em
Guaratuba né aqui no litoral do Paraná
tava com alguns amigos e era festa do
divino quem conhece acesso Divino a
famosa e daí passando na frente uma casa
uma das amigas que tava com a gente vira
que fala Essa aqui era a casa das bruxas
é aqui que elas matavam as crianças e
enterrar vão no quintal de casa
é aquilo ficou na minha cabeça eu não
lembrava dos detalhes a história porque
eu era muito pequeno
eu nasci 83 mas eu lembro muito de 1992
e as crianças desaparecidas eu lembro
especialmente de está esperando a minha
tia me buscar para ir para o Colégio
onde ela trabalhava e eu estudava e
olhava bastante o cartaz do menino
Guilherme tiburtius aquele primeiro que
vocês estão vendo né aqui na
apresentação
e depois usamos passaram e eu fiquei com
aquele negócio da minha amiga dizendo
aquele que matar umas Bruxas eu lembrei
da história das bruxas de Guaratuba como
é o caso era famoso na época
quando a gente começou a verem em
jornais e
somente programas televisivos policiais
que eram começavam a ganhar força
naquela época início da década de 90
passava na hora do almoço e eu lembro de
garoto foi morto em ritual macabro e
coisas do tipo e e não pouco mais longe
a gente via as matérias esse menino foi
vítima de um crime satânico Esses são os
bárbaros bruxo confessa que matou o
outro menino e em resumo da história Era
17 pessoas em Guaratuba que teriam
matado o menino Evandro Ramos Caetano de
7 anos de idade no dia sete de sete de
abril de 1992 alguma das pessoas teriam
confessado e nesse caso teria se
arrastado por décadas e até o dia que eu
parei para pensar um pouco sobre isso e
eu fiquei me perguntando existem seitas
satânicas que praticam rituais de
sacrifício humano
e essa é uma pergunta
incomum mas que eu fico sempre surpresa
com a quantidade de pessoas que têm uma
certeza absoluta que isso acontece e eu
sempre que eu perguntava por dados
porque eu sou uma pessoa extremamente
pragmática nesse ponto eu digo eu estou
disposto a acreditar mas eu gostaria das
evidências sobre isso então eu comecei a
pesquisar sobre isso e eu comecei a me
perguntar coisas básicas Tipo o quê que
é o diabo o que que é um mal e por que
alguém conseguiria me aparecerem lógica
a ideia de OK tá aqui a figura do que
tudo representa de ruim no mundo e no
universo e eu vou segui-la por livre
espontânea vontade por qualquer motivo
que seja mas eu estava disposto a
acreditar eu tava tão disposto acreditar
que eu fiz um mestrado sobre isso
estudando esse cara aqui
O que é um Mago inglês uniseculo vim
chamado alester Crowley que tinha o
Carinhoso apelido de o anticristo e eles
querem uma série de livros ele fuma uma
filosofia uma religião chamada telemann
e eu decidi o que será que o anticristo
pensava sobre o bem eo mal então eu fiz
uma mestrado na pouco na PUC de São
Paulo a essência da religião sobre
noções de ética e moral em alester
Crowley tá disponível aí para baixar
quem quiser a dissertação de Mestrado
não contente com isso terminei o
mestrado né não encontrei o diabo
continuei procurando ele e encontrei uma
vez um livro muito interessante que me
ajudou muito nas minhas aulas de
história da arte quando dava aqui na
ponte no curso arquitetura
e até o ano passado e é um livro chamado
pensando com demônios e que tem essa
frase do Historiador Stuart Clark que
ele falava com aproximação do fim do
mundo no inferno abre suas portas era
essa sensação que se tinha no período em
que a inquisição ficou mais forte e é
curioso pensar em inquisição e queimas
das bruxas e enfim A Caçada Terezinha
Rios porque geralmente a gente começa a
achar que isso é coisa da idade média e
o curiosamente aqui não é o período o
pior período da Inquisição
geralmente a gente está falando século
16 que já é idade moderna então a
transição da idade média para a idade
moderna é que acontecem os piores crimes
exatamente espera as crianças com a
humanidade contra a humanidade nesse
sentido com correndo atrás de Bruxas e
diabo
com o objetivo de limpar o mundo das
suas impurezas e com muito medo do que
essa coisa chamada ciência tá trazendo
as tá trazendo coisas que vieram lá do
Renascimento
bom então tem o tem uma história que
voltarmos contar com os meus alunos
especialmente saber arquitetura sobre
essa igreja em Munique que tem essa
pegada ela é chamada de a pegada do
diabo porque Diz a lenda que o arquiteto
ele teria feito um pacto com o demônio
que para ter fundos para construir sua
igreja ele faz um pacto e daí ele teria
prometido para o diabo que essa igreja
não teria janelas e daí o diabo for na
igreja ficou pronta Ele entrou na igreja
viu que não tinha janelas e avançar um
pouco mais ele percebeu que tinha umas
janelas escondidos atrás das pilastras e
a luz do sol entrou e acabou
fazendo o diabo virar fumaça e daí ficou
só a pegada dele a sua história muito
interessante só tem um problema logo no
final da igreja tem uma grande janela
então a lenda não faz sentido quando
você vê os fatos
E tem também o famoso caso do Simão de
Trento em
1435 é uma coisa chamada libelo de
sangue que era geralmente uma criança
que cristãos tinham na época de que
judeus estavam sacrificando crianças
para usar o seu sangue para qualquer
motivo que seja e Simão de Trento daí um
caso famoso dentro da igreja católica
enfim eu não vou entrar em detalhes Mas
isso é um dos maiores casos de
antissemitismo que nós temos na história
EA percepção de judeus todo Editora
Idade Média o libelo de sangue é um dos
grandes exemplos disso
eu sou apaixonada especialmente por
rituais
que estão a questões não né os manuais
de bruxaria que tentam investigar os
rituais que as bruxas Teoricamente
fariam e tem um manual específicos
pessoal geralmente conhece o malleus
maleficarum né uma tela das bruxas mas
tem um que eu sou apaixonada que eu
compreendi um ali ficaram que tem uma
série de ilustrações tem um famosa
descrição do nosso como obsceno que
seria o beijo que a bruxa e no anos o
diabo para fazer para selar o pacto né
Aqui tem essa imagem que eu sempre achei
muito curiosa século 17 que dizer que
bruxa sacrificam crianças e nós vemos
aliás duas crianças praticadas ali no
canto superior direito e outra que mais
Central
o que uma das minhas histórias
prediletas sobre o diabo também é o das
Freiras de London
supostamente no século 17 na Cidade
francesa de London
um monte de freira foi possuída pelo
demônio tiveram que fazer um Exorcismo
público com todas elas e
depois a inquisição foi investigar
descobrir os que teria sido um padre que
teria feito um pacto com o demônio
Vendendo as almas das freiras e como
prova inclusive encontraram esse pacto
esse
documento se encontrar escrito em latim
com as assinaturas dos demônios embaixo
e daí esse Padre foi para fogueira o
fato esse pare de ter problemas
políticos com a igreja católica e que os
quais foram os locais uma mera
coincidência é claro
e não é ficar me perguntando se isso
tudo foi real
é porque até o momento eu tô tentando
procurando procurar o diabo ainda eu
ainda não estou encontrando estou
encontrando explicações para mim parece
muito mais plausíveis com uma diferença
que eu achei essencial na Idade Média
você não tinha muita escolha o mundo era
Deus existe e a partir de Deus a gente
vai ver como ele funciona então se Deus
Existe existe o diabo com uma força
opositora nós temos que entender como
que funciona então isso era era ciência
da época só que daí a gente começa a
entrar no Iluminismo a gente começa a
entrar nos limites da religião e da
ciência ele começa a se perguntar se
isso ainda existe até hoje
do pop
mundo avançou né eu cheguei em 2015 de
alguma forma em 2015 eu lancei um
podcast chamado projeto humanos que era
um podcast focado em histórias de
pessoas né forma narrativa a primeira
temporada foi sobre uma sobrevivente do
holocausto que eu entrevistei contei a
sua história Segunda Temporada foi sobre
guerra na Síria e crise de refugiados
e na quarta Temporada eu finalmente
decidi entrar na história do caso
Evandro
e eu rebati usei o caso de Guaratuba eu
não fui o primeiro só do They o nome que
já era utilizado especialmente no mundo
judiciário e o primeiro episódio foi ao
ar no dia Trinta e Um de outubro de 2018
dia das bruxas i e pode propósito né
madeira lance alguns Episódios
vende os direitos de adaptação do
podcast para uma série na Globo e agora
tá no globoplay Fez bastante sucesso
Ainda bem
e investigando a história é o seguir uma
linha de investigação que não foi
seguida na época e encontrei provas de
que as pessoas que tinham confessado
foram torturados
nós estamos em 2020 Março 2020 ano
passado 7 dias antes de eu começar a me
entregar em casa por causa pandemia a
maior história da minha vida foi
engolida pela polimento do coronavírus
mas todas as nossas vidas foram Então OK
mas o que merece temos plantado é se não
fosse Aquela minha amiga fazendo aquela
frase aqui era onde as bruxas mataram as
crianças essas pessoas até hoje estariam
sendo considerado culpado por que
confessaram e quando eu encontrei as
provas
é muito difícil ouvir tortura
e é muito difícil você ser o primeiro ao
vivo um áudio em que mostra as pessoas
sendo torturadas você tem que uma suas
mãos para os por meses e tentando ver
como que você apresenta isso para não
dar dúvidas do tipo a ser torturado não
significa que é inocente uma frase que
eu ouço de vez em quando e não importa
se o seu mostro para as pessoas Olha que
eles mentindo Olha que eles mentiram
para sobreviver não adianta as pessoas
ainda preferem acreditar em bicho papão
oi e daí eu me perguntei se isso já
aconteceu em mais algum lugar e daí eu
lembrei de uma série de documentários
que eu vi alguns anos atrás muitos anos
muito antes do caso levanto de assistir
de fazer o caso Evandro que é o famoso
caso West memphis' three que é uma
trilogia documentário chamado parte da
islote que esses três garotos foram
acusados de matar crianças na cidade de
West Memphis as crianças foram mortas
por encontradas amarradas nuas e esses
meninos eles eram metaleiros eles ouviam
os usavam Preto cabelo comprido gostavam
de metal e daí então eles eram os
esquisitos Logo eles eram satanistas
logo esse mandar essas crianças por
conta disso parece um absurdo mas o caso
é basicamente isso teve que ter uma
grande mobilização nos Estados Unidos em
uma série artistas para essas crianças
hoje adultos esses jovens
poderem ter algum senso de justiça
acontecer no finalmente isso virou
documentário parte das gostem filme
livro chamar e o nó do diabo
e daí uma pergunta que eu acho justa a
gente fazer como que a gente acredita
nisso em pleno século vinte
E como que é possível acreditar que é
mais fácil ter uma seita satânica
matando crianças o que um serial killer
um assassino que ficou Maluco na hora
porque a gente prefere acreditar
nascentes a tônica tem eu percebi eu
descobri que tinha gente tudo isso vai
fazer muito tempo especialmente uma
estaca de 90 especialmente um sociólogo
americano já aposentado chamada de Jeff
Victor e ele tem esse livro chamado
satanic Panic Diz ele que foi o cara que
cunhou o termo Pânico satânico que eu
não conhecia existe uma disputa para ver
quem é exatamente criou esse termo mas a
ideia mais ou menos seguinte ele se ele
se enquadra a gente uma categoria de
estudar na sociologia chamado de ir
pânicos Morais e o pânico satânico é a
ideia de que existem poderosos que
adoram o diabo e eles estão na polícia
são na política eles estão entre nós tem
Agentes do diabo espalhados por aqui
escondidos e eles se organizam em algum
lugar e começam a e danças abusar de
crianças mulheres etc etc e eles bebem o
sangue dessas pessoas
é bem eu descobri que tinha o FBI
investigando isso por um bom tempo esse
cá esse é um relatório feito por um cara
chamado Kenneth Lenin
curiosamente 1992 também e o Lenny ele é
um cara que estudou por durante
investigou durante a vida inteira caso
de abusos sexuais contra crianças e ele
começou a se espantar como na década de
80 começou a receber muito muita
denúncia de que em certa cidade teria um
grupo de crianças sendo abusadas
sexualmente na creche na escola alguma
coisa assim por Adoradores do diabo e
daí ele falava que se espantava com onde
deveria haver provas disso não tinha e
era centenas de casa acontecendo Ele
percebeu uma epidemia
satânica aconteceu nos Estados Unidos o
Jeff Victor eu quero que os clientes
para vocês ele catalogou assim cerca de
dezena de casos Só indo para bibliotecas
e lendo jornais da época e vendo o quê é
dito sobre supostos satanistas abusando
e matando pessoas e o Lenny ele faz aqui
uma uma uma
coisa muito interessante ele fica uma
conclusão interessante que ele fala
assim o problema de você de você
acreditar que existe um satanista
abusando de criança é que você às vezes
esquece do óbvio que a maior parte dos
casos de abuso contra criança não fez
quanto parente por parentes próximos
Então você acreditar em sair tá satânica
em pleno século vinte que tá fazer
comentando crimes você evita de resolver
crimes e atrás os verdadeiros criminosos
E aí no século 21 Só que melhoramos lá
para cá
e daí eu lembro
2018 quando sete pessoas foram acusados
de terem participado de ritual satânico
em Novo Hamburgo na grande Porto Alegre
porque tinha um cara cara satanista na
cidade declarado ele tinha um templo
satânico você pode não gostar mas
satanismo é uma religião
Quem gostou não existe liberdade
religiosa Teoricamente somos um país
secular sa37 certa mas o cara tem um
templo satânico eu não quero saber eu
não acho que é de bom grado assim você
talvez é um pouco complicado dependendo
o mundo que você vive mas esses caras
acabaram sendo acusados de terem matado
criança Sem prova alguma o delegado
depois falou que como ele era evangélico
um profeta da sua igreja tive tem uma
visão que as crianças foram mortas no
templo satânico e por isso as pessoas
foram presos
2021 nós acabamos de ver o caso Lázaro
em que foram Teoricamente contado
objetos na casa do criminoso e
apareceram esses objetos que depois
falaram que era um terreiro
a sua amizade no terreiro que falaram
que era um objeto satânico lá só possa
mexer na sua casa e é curioso como as
religiões de matriz africana daí acabou
sendo Associados com satanismo nesse
caso coisa que não tem nada a ver uma
coisa com a outra e é muito
significativo como no caso Evandro tudo
acontece porque alguns membros eram
seguidores de umbanda
é esse o caso mais emblemático é o do
que o anon a Teoria da Conspiração que
dominou boa parte do Partido Republicano
nos Estados Unidos e que resultou
especialmente
a mãe passou no Capitólio me disse esse
ano é a ideia de que o partido Democrata
é dominado por satanistas e pedófilos
e quando você acredita em uma teoria da
conspiração existe uma tendência isso
acreditar em todas e isso destrói vidas
satanismo seitas satânicas bicho papão
tudo isso é Teoria da Conspiração até
que me provem o contrário
eu gosto encerrar mostrando essa imagem
aqui daquela casa que eu mandei para
vocês antes hoje é um estacionamento a
família baixa foi destruída por causa
disso e eles são sortudos Por que eles
estão vivos deve gente que morreu na
cadeia
é Aonde que tá o diabo eu passei minha
vida inteira procurando pelo diabo e eu
não encontrei
mas eu encontrei Muita maldade feita por
homens bem obrigado
E aí